So, I want to play
a little game with you.
Okay.
It's called "Mouth Sounds"!
[ applause ]
Uh, uh, uh, uh...
uh, uh, uh...
Now, I'll pick the sound,
'cause it's my show.
You're gonna do
an airplane.
A Cessna 310R.
Okay.
I'll put five seconds
on the clock.
Here we go.
Ha ha.
Go!
[ imitating plane engine ]
Okay.
[ imitation continues ]
[ buzzer sounds ]
And you're out of time!
[ imitates engine acceleration ]
It came back up.
[ imitates alarm beeping ]
I'm concerned about the plane.
What's happening to it now?
[ imitates plane crash ]
Oh, no! Did they hit a goose?
[ imitation continues ]
Are you gonna do
a water landing, Reggie?
[ imitates explosion ]
Aah! I can see the flames!
[ bell rings ]
Reggie,
I can see the flames.
Hot dog!
Hot dog! Hot damn!
Yes!
Hot diggity
mother[ bleep ]
dog doo.